as mclaughlin he got blocked by the  cleanup crew on the floor missed the  shot in waters cleans up the mist this  is that crazy play mclaughlin i don't  think that he was ready he was looking  behind him to see if there were any  thunder players coming in as mclaughlin  he got blocked by the cleanup crew on  the floor missed the shot in waters  cleans up the mist this is that crazy  play mclaughlin i don't think that he  was ready he was looking behind him to  see if there were any thunder players  coming in as mclaughlin he got blocked  by the cleanup crew on the floor missed  the shot in waters cleans up the mist  this is that crazy play mclaughlin i  don't think that he was ready he was  looking behind him to see if there were  any thunder players coming in